radical left's new coveted spending bill
is raising eyebrows with how it's
handing out cash
for example even convicted murderers
will get a check from taxpayers
senator tom cotton says it includes the
likes of dylann roof
and the boston marathon bomber
look how crazy some of the democratic
ideas are i mean they had a chance on
saturday morning to stop checks from
going to prisoners
from going to the boston bomber for
instance and on that vote
they declined every single democrat
wanted to continue the practice of
sending checks to prisoners
the two other stimulus packages included
similar payments but as senator cotton
said democrats blocked republicans from
trying to stop it
and we know the bill has more than one
trillion dollars of spending that has
nothing to do with the pandemic the wall
street journal says it creates
quote the coveted welfare state because
it showers people with cash without
actually requiring them to work dana
what do you make of this is this where
we are
that you know we can't agree on not
sending money to murderers
i was trying to find the democrats
defense of this and i saw
senator dick durbin one of the things he
said is that if you didn't allow these
payments that it might hurt the children
of prisoners but the thing is like then
if you are talking about dylann roof
and zarniv neither of them have children
so that's not going to work but
i mean that's that was their defense i
think what it really shows degan is that
be ready for more of this
it really crystallizes the mind for how
devastating it was for republicans to
lose those two senate races in georgia
because you can't even get joe manchin
the supposedly moderate
senator from west virginia to agree with
republicans on this
issue then you're probably not going to
get much bipartisan support at all
and the rep and the democrats are going
to be in lockstep and watch they made a
shift
including mansion looks like i think
that they are going to try to take on
the filibuster and then
katie bar the door yeah on everything
right jesse but
again if this kind of spending blows up
inflation
uh regular folks notice that and it
could come by
back to bite them in the behind and it
might be four years from less than four
years from now but it'll eventually hit
them
yeah the democrats will own high gas
prices high food prices since the
republicans didn't vote for that and a
lot of the spending doesn't even really
kick in until
years gone by it looks like the
democrats know they already have the
lower class depended on government now
they're trying to get the
middle class and upper middle class i
mean you could be making six figures and
still get checks coming in
i'd like to see when democrat
politicians stop those checks i don't
see that happening
anytime soon the trump irs was trying to
block these payments to these mass
murderers
until a guy incarcerated for grand theft
auto out in california
got a little class action lawsuit
together to keep the payments flowing
guess what kind of lawyer took that
action a
radical left-wing democrat lawyer with
big donations to obama biden
the dnc and crying chuck and then she
won
because there's nothing in the language
that says these guys can't get the
payments so maybe
when joe biden's rested enough peter
ducey can ask him why
white supremacist mass shooters and
radical islamic bombers and child
rapists
are getting taxpayer money when they're
on death row what do they even need the
money for
yeah juan you can't be behind that
you know yeah i'm just struck by this
conversation because this bill
is so incredibly popular with the
american people
republicans and democrats and it just
sounds to me like republicans are
grasping at straws
trying to find a way to make it less
popular
to somehow say this is the worst bill
ever but it's just not the worst bill
ever i mean
it's not just about you know degen you
know
you're talking about you have to make a
distinction between prisoners jails and
of course it wasn't
and i think that's part of the democrats
problem you know somebody could be
getting out of jail and all of a sudden
they're not eligible
so you know there's lots there but the
key point to me
is that even if you were not in jail
in jail if you were employed unemployed
if you are poor if you are rich if the
republicans had been in charge and they
were in charge under trump remember
nobody'd be getting any money nobody
this this relief bill wouldn't be
happening and the american people say
that in the
aftermath of covet and the tremendous
damage it's done to the american economy
government should be helping the people
and especially
the working class and middle class
people of this country
the small business owners the people who
are out there who've been unemployed
they are they want they want help
politico has a story today about
republican governors
and mayors across the country saying
please stop it
to the republicans in the senate we want
this bill
greg juan sounds like he's talking to
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
and talking to them last fall when they
were tap dancing and dragging their feet
trying to hurt
president trump up for re-election and
wouldn't move
on a stimulus leaving at least a
trillion dollars on the table initially
because of nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer
and the democrats wouldn't even let a
stimulus go up for debate in the fall
so who really gives a damn about the
suffering of american people because
they need people needed the money then
less so now because
vaccine yeah what uh it everything you
just said i was gonna say but you just
said it
no that's true it's like uh they uh she
let
i mean the i want saying if they would
be in charge they were in charge
and pelosi let the american public twist
in the wind
because they wanted to get rid of trump
so it was pelosi who held off relief
while people were getting sick and
people were dying and people were losing
their jobs and their businesses
the fact is the reason why this bill is
so popular
is that it's huge so no one reads it and
two
it gives everyone money of course people
are gonna like something
that they didn't read but gives them
money politicians know that politicians
love being there to sign the check but
they don't like the responsibility
of actually that comes with it seeing
where it goes and what it does
i'm interested like what does i mean
some people should some people should
think about this
like what does a person do with sixteen
hundred dollars when they're in death
row is there an atm
yeah do they go do they or do they mail
it to deposit it at wells fargo
i mean this is this is our money it's
kind of a sacred
thing shouldn't people actually want to
care that like
let me do the math here there are um 713
000 violent criminals multiply that by
1400 it's 998 million that's one billion
dollars maybe you could be interested
in finding out what happens to the
billion dollars and and craft a simple
solution
which is cross reference it and then
when the checks come to the prison
they don't get them how easy is that
i did that in 10 minutes less than 10
minutes
thanks well done coming up this